so this is what happened second season
of Crime
Story all right was
shooting the day uh you know like in
Casino how they blew uh um Robert daero
they blew up his car right okay in crime
story I got blown out of a car so they
have me in a cast right like from the
waist up and Michael man's directing and
it was the only episode he directed in
two seasons of of Crime Story and the
word on the street was they're going to
cancel crime story because of
ratings so I go over to Michael man and
I go we really need to talk you know you
can't cancel the show and he goes all
right when when we take a break me and
you are going to go get coffee so he
puts me in his Trans Am and it was the
old Vegas that we knew with the dunes
and right he was cutting through the
desen in his Trans Am and I'm wearing a
cast like this in the and we got it a
Peppermill so we're having coffee and
he's looking at me and I'm 20 I'm I'm 20
how old am I in your 20 no I'm 29 years
old okay okay it's the second cuz I got
Crime Story 27 and he goes all right
tell me why I can't cancel the show he
goes number one dice it's a very
expensive show to film now think of this
half a million dollars an episode what
would that you couldn't shoot anything
like that today you know this was a 196
today it would cost like 8 million an
episode to do that but he would have no
say over whether it's canceled or not
it's the network no it was the network
and it was with new world yeah who who
put up the money he goes expensive show
nobody has really catapulted you know
like the covers of magazines all that
like when David Caruso got let's say
mypd blue and he's on every magazine
cover right all right so I'm looking at
him I'm smoking through the cast you
know you know drinking coffee I go
listen to me I go I'm GNA tell you a
little secret that you don't know and he
goes yeah what's the big secret you know
that's Michael man that's how he talk I
go just give me three months and I'll be
the biggest star in the world you said
that to Michael man yeah and and and he
goes what are you talking about what do
you mean you know I go I just shot this
Rodney D field young comedian special
right and when it ISS I'm going to be
the biggest comic in the world I I even
edited the spot Rodney let me edit the
spot cuz I didn't like what he showed
me and he basically laughs in my face he
goes okay so three months you're the
biggest star in the world he goes look
dice I love you as an actor you know I
really think you have a future as an
actor he goes but it's an expensive show
that cancelling the show I mean I wish
you a lot of luck with the the skit you
did with Rodney you know I go no it's
it's not what you're thinking I go this
is something that's never happened
before in the world of standup you know
and I even took out an ad in
variety two days before the special
ad and the ad basically read big half a
page was me and the other half said in
big bald letters I never studied much in
school but when I turned on the tube and
I talked about Elvis being the king
Buddy Rich with hands like lightning
Travolta sang and dance all these
different names of people I watched and
in the end I said Murphy and PRI both
great no doubt but in 88 it's dice th
shout I never studied much in school but
I did study
and I put Rodney Dangerfield special
Saturday night
whatever now if I was wrong you know I
would just look like a jerk off to the
whole industry right and the show had on
Saturday night Monday on the biggest
comic in the world within six months I'm
selling out Arenas the way I remember it
is you got a lot of heat off of that and
then you got your own special never
needed it never even needed the special
I was already doing the arenas were the
first guy to play Arenas before like the
chappels and the and all these other
people he was wait did that stop the
cancellation of the show then were you
right but no no the the show got
cancelled I actually the the the
punchline of it is I run into Michael
man about two years late and now I'm
just doing you know the biggest things
in in standup imaginable you know I'm
doing 880,000 people a week in concert
so I run into Michael man at a
party and and he looks at me and we're
just hanging out and he goes look he
goes whatever his he was like 40
something years old you know and he goes
if some kid came over to you and go give
me three months I'll be the biggest star
in the world wouldn't you laugh in his
face like I did and I go yeah it makes a
point I just knew what was coming you
know so I always knew what I was
supposed to do in my
career
he